[Music]
in stupid games news Oh play stupid
games win stupid prizes they sure did
Oh submitted by doe goes like hot dog oh
don't people's dogs
judo men were arrested for taking turns
shooting each other in a bulletproof
vest thank you and Joe oh my god I
probably would if I was under 25 I'm
actually I wouldn't I wouldn't that's so
scary yeah you would shoot okay who's
the person that would shoot BB guns are
whoa yeah in the back yard
dude we lost Joe oh yeah right here but
a real gun that's the scary I'm not like
proving the point of the the bulletproof
vest like this up really worth
appointment oh you're not that good of a
shouter most people aren't so if you
just are off like this it can go into
there you'll just die it's a fatal
mistake oh wow it's not like punching
each other in the arm well at least it
wasn't as stupid as well I want you to
rest in peace but dude you were dumb as
[ __ ] no one guy had the YouTuber guy
that got the dick ass book or the Bible
book and then like he made his
girlfriend shoot yeah yeah think he was
it for YouTube well he thought that a
phone book was gonna stop a bullet
yeah what's our really social experience
this even a cinderblock can't stop a
bullet you know wait and she was like
yeah like whatever you see in the movies
like when they dug behind a car and
they're like we're behind a couch I'm
like come on it's a nice couch pong got
a lower caliber gun we'll look for that
in that case is more dangerous because
if it doesn't there's no exit wound
it just bounces inside you or some [ __ ]
and it just tears all your [ __ ] up yeah
Wow
yes though it's better for it to go in
and then out the other so your body
doesn't absorb the shock and I'll just
keep like bouncing inside because it's
not strong enough it's like you know
when you like have a dull knife and you
kind of tomato and doesn't go all the
way through yeah so it's not strong
enough to go through your back so once
it goes inside I'll go in and then like
it starts to explode and fragments come
off so it just it just turns into a
bunch of other [ __ ]
it doesn't exit though sorry Twitter for
Italy yeah yeah yeah it's cleaner
yeah that's really stupid and I'm
sir but maybe they were experienced
shooters because if they didn't like the
bulletproof vest can only cover so much
I think if they were experienced they
would hurt like a mother football yeah
yeah and I've heard but if you have a
mother professor I may just go spoon you
know what I mean it's not like it's
still like a horse [ __ ] like kicking
you in the [ __ ] chest funny
you don't wanna know man 56 hey that's
pretty crazy okay so it was 50 and 3600
five and the 650 and 3640 been hangin
out after certain age or kick it you
know you just kick there's nothing to do
water than they leave Florida Arkansas
oh just like not a lot to do over there
and they're like we have guns and
bulletproof vests and they probably have
a big plot of land they probably share a
toothbrush how do they get caught was
this on youtube no brothers one of the
dudes
he had this red spot on his upper chest
and so he went to the hospital and he
had this very elaborate story saying
that he was hit multiple times because
he had this asset that paid him $200 for
protection so they met this other man at
around 10 p.m. and they just ended up in
a gunfight so that's how he got shot
what a loser
and then he said that he was taken to
the hospital by the so called asset I
love that he's using these terms news by
winking of a 50 year old by the way the
older guys so then the wife was like no
that's not what happened he was drinking
with his neighbor a thousand morning
that's when they started just wearing
these bulletproof vests and so the 50
year old shot the neighbor with the 22
caliber semi-automatic rifle I think
smaller he's a smaller so then that's
what he ended up getting pissed and he
unloaded his clip into the other dude
talk [ __ ]
yeah and so the friend was struck five
times in the back one of the bullets
pierced it oh [ __ ] that's a good shot
yeah so then a neighbor said that there
was as many as fifty to a hundred rounds
at a time
what and they never got struggled any of
it oh man they were drunk Jesus on their
side farm Horgan lucky yeah a hundred
[ __ ] rounds and these bulletproof
vests they're not meant to take that
many rounds so I think that are lucky
that it's a 22 so it's just a way
smaller bullet but like let's say if a
bulletproof vest is rated for a
9-millimeter maybe ten shots and I'll
start going through by the way they were
both sharing one bus that's and I would
be like I'm pissed here if you do share
toothbrush Oh toothbrush cool like
alright alright you go you go you know
what I mean but they were actually
pissed so there was like what this
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright guy was like no no
no no so first it was like oh look I got
this bulletproof vest we're drinking
we're drunk whatever the [ __ ] here put
this on and then he shot him and then
the guy that got shot for the first time
is like you left me a mark mmm he ended
up giving him the chance boy ended up
like unloading the clip so anyway here's
a photo of them you decided was the 50
year-old who's a 32 oh my gosh 50 36 now
I was thinking the other where's concern
is he's on the right we don't know I
think 50 is on the right no I probably
do know I got a look at the article
again but is that a guardians of the
galaxy t-shirt it looks like Little Wolf
the ones I like oh it's like a wolf in
like a [ __ ] you do see the ears you see
the ears Oh true it does really good
ears and up on wipes oh they're in a
forest oh lucky that they were good at
shooting while drunk too so 36 year old
was on the left okay yeah it looks like
it the wolf they don't they look really
close in age this is 36 oh this is 36
Wow I was wrong that's crazy that's
gonna be me next year you know that I'm
gonna be 36 next year what you look like
makes you feel good about yourself like
insanely younger
yeah 36 younger that's crazy
six that's all wild I met you when you
were 28 27 is someone down there so
[ __ ] crazy the median Dan time goes
by too fast dude how old are you I was
24 23 for you oh I was a little baby
dude me too I think that's 23 31 no no
Matt you guys
we met Isaak at like 3 he was born this
year 37 next year yeah that's yeah I
think so Rikers away from 40 next year
you should have oh my god but you don't
look at all
no yeah you may be however old you want
as long as I look like that [ __ ] isn't
that crazy when you see some of your
friends from high school and they look
like hot garbage yeah what they're like
man brother it's like you look like you
haven't changed much I'm like you have
all that [ __ ] what happen your
face dude did you [ __ ] fall asleep in
dirt for the past 10 years what happened
yeah I think wants people and they're
unhappy well I used to think once people
had kids like it just like drained like
women I drain the life out of them but I
mean you're not a good example of that
you look great
you look great too well you were Teen
Mom yeah yeah for the next time I'm
gonna be drained [ __ ] then you'll
finally look 22
I went to my high school reunion it
wasn't even my idea my best friend
wanted to go so he made me go do it man
some of these people hot trash dude
really if you guys are watching this
video I'm sorry but age and father time
beat the living [ __ ] out of you dude
like it's almost like when you give up
on personal goals like your body feels
it too and a lot of these people that I
were taught that I was talking to they
kind of just like they still relish in
their high school days yeah you remember
back high school was the best I also
know it wasn't
me too you talking about but the people
who'd spoke like that it reflects in
their skin how they look how they carry
themselves and if they don't have goals
outside of what they thought their
people's was in high school is just
everything went downhill from there they
literally look like [ __ ] I think maybe
because like if you think high school
was the best time of your life
alien already happen you're like well
what the [ __ ] do you look forward to
okay you know that's kind of really sad
I know I know like someone I went to
high school with like sad it's really
sad like they just don't have any goals
and ambitions they still live at home
with their parents they don't they still
work minimum-wage jobs to the point
where like and then they still go to a
community college for the past how long
have I been at 11 well like you 11 years
I've been at a high school after working
on their PhD I've never gotten a single
degree like not even an a a man can't
you know that were cousins like that
he's been in Community College for a
minute sometimes it takes people but not
even at the 30 30 see sometimes it's
been taken to admit I think he's like
starting to like get his [ __ ] together
but he's been a community college since
since he was 18
he's like 31 now but it takes a minute
for some people English no calling me
and they'll be like oh yeah you know I
was walking today you don't have a car
okay I'm like it's looks like it really
sucks to know someone like that and just
and in trying to help them over the
years and trying to like motivate them
or something and nothing happens and
it's you're sweet as [ __ ] yeah I'm just
like oh and I think you have to learn or
know that everybody is where they want
to be yeah cuz if you want to be
somewhere you will push yourself to be
in that place and if you're okay in
those circumstances like we're not have
you know a car with having a
minimum-wage job like you do you you
know you could never push somebody to do
more that's actually do what you want
that you've been and you last maybe like
like three years I think right like
three years that I've just kind of like
let go of that person I'm like I can't
okay not your burden yeah I don't even
know how to help you is just it
shouldn't be your burden this like why
why is it on your shoulders right she
didn't you know she's not working at the
same level you she didn't say it was a
she I mean we assume it's a she for sure
you said he
oh did I yeah oh well [ __ ] that guy girl
every whether it's a female yeah but
that sucks though I mean it's because
you know you feel like connected to that
person from you know all those old
feelings so you want them to do better
exactly what you're saying like that's
all they can talk about is like high
school don't remember high school dude
the like I don't do remember high
schools like no I don't I don't remember
high school at all like oh you know what
I do remember my film getting into
Sundance did you see that film then one
I made $0 great
[Music]